il continue de dire insurrection
clairement il n'y a pas eu
d'insurrection mac donald trump n'est
pas responsable des émeutes du capitole
le 6 janvier dernier
voilà la défense adoptée par ses avocats
et ces derniers ont parachevé leur
argumentaire ce vendredi afin de
contester toute implication de l'ancien
président dans ces événements vidéo à
l'appui
l'équipe de juristes évoque un procès
injustifié cette procédure de
destitution est complètement détachée
des faits des preuves et des intérêts du
peuple américain
le sénat devrait voter rapidement et
largement pour la rejeter
touré jacked aucune personne qui
réfléchit ne croirai sérieusement que le
discours du président le 6 janvier à
l'ellipse était une quelconque
incitation à la violence ou à
l'insurrection
cette suggestion est totalement absurde
de prime d'abord pourtant c'est bien
pour ces faits que donald trump est
poursuivi l'ancien chef d'état avait
appelé ses partisans à refuser les
résultats de l'élection présidentielle
donnant jeu byden vainqueur et des moore
qui n'aurait aucunement incité
l'invasion du capitole selon les avocats
de donald trump les criminels au
capitole n'était pas à l'ellipse pour
entendre les mots du président il était
à plus d'un kilomètre et demi dans leurs
attaques planifiées à l'avancé contre ce
bâtiment c'était une attaque planifiée à
l'avancé ne vous y trompez pas et c'est
un fait crucial la défense de donald
trump joue la carte non coupable face
aux accusations des procureurs
démocrates pour ses avocats l'ancien
président appelait simplement à une
manifestation pacifique et pour appuyer
leurs dires ils ont accusé la partie
adverse de vouloir faire tomber un
adversaire politique
il demande de permettre à la cancel
kutcher constitutionnel de s'emparer du
sénat des états unis
allons-nous permettre au bannissement à
l'interdiction à la censure d'être
toléré par cette institution
s'il vous plaît arrêtez l'hypocrisie
et avez vous modérez votre rhétorique
l'été dernier lorsque se déroulaient les
manifestations après la mort de georges
floyd avez vous condamnez les émeutiers
bien étiez-vous du côté de nancy pelosi
qui a dit les gens feront ce qu'ils ont
à faire
place ce samedi aux réclamations des
deux parties avant le vote du sénat
si deux tiers des élus votent en faveur
d'une destitution donald trump ne pourra
plus se présenter à des élections mais
pour cela le camp démocrate devra
récolter ses 50 voix ainsi que 17 voix
républicaine une configuration qui
semble compliqué à atteindre
au vu de la popularité de l'ancien
président dans le camp républicain
la piste d'un acquittement de donald
trump semble donc privilégié